[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis ein schönen Freitagabend
wünsche ich Ihnen und herzlich
willkommen zu den Nachrichten Fußball
und Handball gibt es von Norbert Lehmann
einen schönen guten Abend schauen wir
auf die weiteren Themen heute
Parteitag mit Konfliktpotenzial
AKW-Laufzeiten Energiekrise und
Waffenlieferungen sorgen für Zündstoff
bei den Grünen
so neben der Migration über den Balkan
Berlin und Brüssel machen Druck auf
Serbien
und Sorge vor Corona Herbst wegen
steigender Zahlen stellt
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
eine neue corona-kampagne vor
[Musik]
für die Grünen geht zur Zeit beim
Bundesparteitag in Bonn darum ob sie in
der Ampelkoalition einige dicke Kröten
schlucken oder nicht
etwa beim Thema Waffenlieferungen für
die Ukraine ja sagen die meisten
Mitglieder aber bei Waffen an
Saudi-Arabien sehen sie rot dann
Stichwort Entlastung wegen der hohen
Energiepreise will der Staat wohl die
gasvorauszahlung im Dezember für alle
übernehmen viele grüne aber fordern
gezieltere Hilfen für ärmere Haushalte
und der größte Aufreger sind aber die
AKW-Laufzeiten verlängern bis Frühjahr
allein dieses Zugeständnis von
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck geht manche
in der Partei schon zu weit Patrizia
Wiedemeier
die Debatte um die Atomkraft sie sorgt
nicht nur in der Ampel für Streit auch
zu Beginn des Parteitags der Grünen
draußen vor der Halle Demos kontra und
pro atomkraft
wir wollen günstigeren Gaspreis wir
wollen günstigeren Strompreis und das
geht nur wenn in den nächsten zwei
Jahren mehr Kohlekraftwerke ans Netz
kommen und die Atomkraftwerke für die
nächsten zwei Jahre noch am Netz bleiben
können unsere klare Message hier an den
Bundesparteitag auch nicht übers Ziel
hinausschießen eine klare pragmatische
Linie fahren ohne Verlängerung von
Atomkraft ohne die Nutzung von
Braunkohle drinnen in der Halle ist klar
die Grünen halten am Atomausstieg fest
werden aber wohl den Vorschlag von
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck mittragen
dass die beiden AKWs im Süden notfalls
noch in den streckbetrieb gehen das
dritte Emsland in Niedersachsen nicht
gleichzeitig werden wir auch klar machen
dass neue Brennstäbe besorgen und damit
der langfristige Wiedereinstieg der
Atomkraft das für uns kein Weg ist
dieses Angebot liegt auf dem Tisch ich
würde mir wünschen dass alle in der
Ampel jetzt Verantwortung übernehmen das
ist schnell eine Lösung gibt den
Forderungen der FDP Atomkraftwerke bis
2024 weiter zu lassen will hier keiner
nachgeben ich würde mal zur Kenntnis
nehmen anstelle der FDP sie haben in
Niedersachsen einen Wahlkampf geführt
für die Rückkehr zur Atomkraft das hat
für sie katastrophal geändert ich denke
mal das wäre dann auch ein Punkt der
auch mit der Partei nur sehr schwer zu
machen wäre es lässt sich noch mal nicht
wegdiskutieren dass Atomkraft keine
Zukunft hat sollten die Grünen heute
abend Robert Habeck den Rücken stärken
dann dürfte der Streit in der Ampel
weitergehen viel Spielraum für
Kompromisse bleibt dem
Wirtschaftsminister nach dem
Parteitagsbeschluss dann nicht mehr
die Flüchtlingszahlen in der EU sind
hoch und das liegt nicht nur am
ukraine-krieg in den letzten Wochen
suchten auch zehntausende Flüchtlinge
über die sogenannte Balkanroute ein Weg
nach Westeuropa in Luxemburg haben die
EU Innenministerin und Minister über die
Situation beraten und machen jetzt Druck
auf Serbien das mitten auf der
Balkanroute liegt das Land müsse seine
visa-regeln verschärfen
über die Lage an der serbischen Grenze
und die Folgen für die EU berichtet
Mutter Hilpert
die ungarische Grenze ist nah sie Campen
wild im serbischen Niemandsland hunderte
junge Männer und einige Familien im
September waren rund 19.000 auf der
Balkanroute so die grenzschutz-agentur
Frontex doppelt so viele wie im
Vorjahresmonat auffällig viele sind
Inder seit August dürfen sie Visum frei
nach Serbien fliegen und wollen dann
weiter wir alle über den ungarischen
Zaun erwischt werden kann weh tun
erzählen uns einige
wir warten hier nur darauf weiter zu
ziehen nach Österreich oder in andere
Länder
über die Balkanroute kommen wieder mehr
flüchtende vor allem Afghanen und Syrer
und so wie Serbien Ungarn oder
Österreich will jedes Land entlang der
Route vor allem sein eigenes
Migrationsproblem lösen österreich hat
nun 213 Prozent mehr Asylanträge als im
Vorjahr aber die meisten ziehen weiter
denn grenznah sind die Unterkünfte knapp
die Regierung verteilt deshalb solche
Bahntickets ins Inland nach Westen
erzählt ein flüchtlingshelfer und
vermutet System weil sie nun quasi auch
Menschen weiterschickt mit der
insgeheimen Hoffnung dass die Menschen
auch in andere EU-Länder weiterfahren
was auch tatsächlich der Fall ist sie
haben ein klares Ziel meist in
Frankreich Italien oder Deutschland die
EU dagegen sucht Iris noch in der
Migrationspolitik
und das Treffen der eu-innenministerin
und Minister hat Isabel Schäfers für uns
beobachtet Isabel gab es da Fortschritte
in der Flüchtlingspolitik
zunächst mal hat man sich eher
zurückversetzt gefühlt und zwar in die
Jahre 2015 und 2016 als die EU ja schon
mal versucht hat gemeinsame Antworten
auf eine flüchtlingskrise zu finden
nicht nur die Zahlen erinnert jetzt an
die Zeit sondern auch die Fragen die
hier heute wieder aufkam so diskutiert
man wieder wie man an den
EU-Außengrenzen illegale Einwanderung
weiter begrenzen kann und vor allem auch
wie man Flüchtlinge innerhalb der EU
solidarisch verteilen kann da ist nach
all diesen Jahren und all den Bemühungen
die der Stadt gefunden haben sind immer
noch einige Länder die das komplett
blockieren ein Minister drückt der ist
heute so aus wir haben eigentlich gar
kein Flüchtlingsproblem denn mit diesen
Zahlen hätte man rechnen können darauf
hätte man sich vorbereiten können
sondern wir haben das Problem dass wir
einfach keine europäische Antwort finden
und so kann man wohl sagen dass der
Fortschritt heute ist dass das Thema mit
voller Wucht zurück auf der Agenda ist
danke für diese Einschätzung Isabel
Schäfers
die britische Regierungschefin Trust hat
ihren Finanzminister quateng entlassen
nach nur sechs Wochen im Amt er stand
wegen der inzwischen ausgesetzten
Steuersenkungspläne unter Druck massive
Turbulenzen auf den Finanzmärkten waren
die Folge quatanks Nachfolger wird der
ehemalige Außen- und Gesundheitsminister
Hand
Trust kündigte zudem eine weitere
Änderung an ihrem umstrittenen
Entlastungspaket an die
Körperschaftsteuer soll nun doch
angehoben werden
steht also massiv unter Druck Andreas
Stamm in London war der geschossste
Finanzminister quartang dann nur sowas
wie ein Bauernopfer
ja definitiv einen Bauernopfer und wohl
der letzte manche sagen verzweifelte
versucht der Premierministerin ihre
eigene Haut zu retten nach und das muss
man betonen nicht mal 40 Tagen im Amt
denn hier wird nicht nur ihr
Finanzminister heute abgewickelt sondern
deren gemeinsame wirtschaftspolitische
Vision dass man mitten in einer
Wirtschaftskrise trotz rekordinflation
trotz Rekordverschuldung Steuern senken
kann und erstmal noch mehr Schulden
auftürmen das hat die Finanzmärkte
aufgeschreckt und die Kreditzinsen sind
in die Höhe geschossen viele
hunderttausende Hauseigentümer bangen
nun ob Sie Ihre nächste Rate werden
zahlen können oder ob Sie Ihr Eigenheim
verlieren die englische Notenbank musste
an einer anderen Stelle Eingreifen
Rentenfonds vor dem Kollaps bewahren mit
Milliardenhilfen also die Altersvorsorge
vieler Briten das hat trust in ihre
konservativen in den Umfragen abstürzen
lassen auf nie gekannte Tiefstwerte
pateng war das Bauernopfer doch nicht
wenige Beobachter und auch viele in
ihrer eigenen Partei erklären heute dass
es wenn es nicht bald besser wird auch
listras bald an den Kragen gehen könnte
dass sie hinter
Street ausziehen muss also für sie ist
weiter eng Dankeschön Andreas Stamm
nach Ankara dort hat das türkische
Parlament einem umstrittenes
Mediengesetz verabschiedet es sieht
Haftstrafen für die Verbreitung von so
wörtlich falschen oder irreführenden
Informationen vor
Journalisten aber auch in Nutzern
sozialer Medien drohen damit bis zu drei
Jahre Gefängnis vor der Parlamentswahl
im nächsten Jahr verschärft die
Regierung damit ihr hartes Vorgehen
gegen Medien
Opposition und kritiker sprechen von
Zensur
zum Krieg in der Ukraine laut russlands
Präsident Putin ist die Mobilisierung
von 300.000 Reservisten bald
abgeschlossen der ukrainische Präsident
selenski war Russland erneut vor die
Männer als Kanonenfutter an die Front zu
schicken dort vor allem im Regionen im
Süden und Osten hat die ukrainische
Armee nach eigenen Angaben in den
vergangenen Wochen etwa 600 Ortschaften
zurückerobert wie die Stadt Liman in der
sich Katrin Eigendorf ein Bild von den
Kriegsschäden machen konnte
fünf Monate haben sie in Angst und
Schrecken gelebt jetzt trauen sich die
ersten Menschen wieder heraus vor dem
Rathaus von Liman verteilt die
stellvertretende Bürgermeisterin Brot
und versprechen alles ist zerstört die
Menschen sind hungrig sobald sich die
Situation stabilisiert wird alles wieder
eröffnet es wird Brot geben und
humanitäre Hilfe in großem Umfang
Liman liegt in Trümmern selbst die
Schule haben die Russen zerstört die
Energieversorgung ist zusammengebrochen
viele Häuser sind ohne Strom und Heizung
Wasser müssen manche aus dem Brunnen
holen zerstört auch die zwei größten
Krankenhäuser die medizinische
Versorgung ist bedroht
ich habe die schwerste Form von Diabetes
ich brauche Insulin und muss Tabletten
einnehmen woher soll ich die Medikamente
bekommen noch reichen sie für eineinhalb
Monate danach weiß ich nicht ich könnte
sterben
wenn wir am Leben bleiben dann bauen wir
die u Maschine wieder auf mit unseren
Kräften wir sind stark wir können alles
noch am Leben zu sein ein Glück am Rande
der Stadt liegen die Toten vor schad in
einem Massengrab Ermittler Bergen die
Leichen bereits am ersten Tag über 50 es
sind ukrainische Soldaten Zivilisten und
auch Kinder
Trost spenden angesichts des Grauens
will Vater Alexander er ist während der
russischen Besatzung geblieben
[Musik]
wir beten für den Frieden dass der
Frieden in unser Land komme und das
alles wieder gut wird
doch selbst die Kirche haben die Russen
nicht verschont auch hier müssen sie
wieder aufbauen
zurück nach Deutschland beim Thema
Corona geht Deutschland in einen
unsicheren Winter die Fallzahlen steigen
rasant es gibt etwa deutlich mehr
erfasste Neuinfektionen als letztes Jahr
zur gleichen Zeit wie man hier auch
sehen kann und dazu kommt wohl eine hohe
Dunkelziffer und in vielen Kliniken
füllen sich die Betten wieder mit
covet-patientinnen und Patienten der
Gesundheitsminister will dem Trend auch
mit Aufklärungen gegentreten mit einer
Kampagne die für mehr Impfungen und
Vorsicht wirbt Ines Trams
anstehen für die Impfung in einer Praxis
in Hamburg sie wollen sich schützen vor
der neuen coronawelle doch dr Parey weiß
zu wenige lassen sich die
Auffrischungsimpfung geben auch weil die
Angst nachlässt das Leute die einfach
das nicht mehr wahrhaben wollen dass
Corona immer noch existiert und
versuchen das zu verdrängen und die muss
man es immer noch mal wieder ein
bisschen in Erinnerung rufen das will
auch Bundesgesundheitsminister
Lauterbach eine bundesweite Kampagne
soll nun für die Impfung werben und für
gegenseitige Vorsicht 84 Menschen stehen
für 84 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland
sie schildern ihre persönlichen Gründe
sich ausreichend zu impfen ich schütze
mich ich schütze mich weil meine Mama
mich braucht je nach Gesundheitszustand
und Alter sollte angepasst werden wie
oft man impft doch die Impfung für
Lauterbach das Mittel der Wahl wenn
jemand jetzt drei Impfungen hat und geht
über zur vierten Impfung und ist über 60
Jahre alt dann reduziert er damit sein
Risiko durch diese zusätzliche Impfung
noch einmal um 90 Prozent für geimpfte
reduziert sich das Risiko an longkurve
zu erkranken so wie es Margarete
stukowski erging seit ihrer Infektion
Anfang des Jahres ist sie arbeitsunfähig
wenn akuter Verlauf vor einigermaßen
mild und danach wurde ich dann halt
nicht mehr gesund ich habe dann
long-coburg bekommen in Form von
täglichen krassen Kopfschmerzen fatik
Herzrasen Schwindel Kribbeln in
verschiedenen Körperteilen
Konzentrationsstörungen
Wortfindungsstörungen auch appelliert
Lauterbach an die Länder erneut eine
maskenpflicht in Innenräumen einzuführen
so wie es das Infektionsschutzgesetz
erlaubt
Corona hat viele erschüttert gerade auch
Kinder schon während der Pandemie wurden
die Folgen von Schulschließungen und
weniger Kontakten sichtbar viele Kinder
und Jugendliche wurden psychisch krank
Schulpsychologinnen und Psychologen
können da helfen aber es gibt einfach zu
wenige von ihnen wie Konstanze Kainz
berichtet
normaler Schulalltag Pausen mit Freunden
doch die Pandemie und aus viele allein
sein zehren noch immer an den Kindern
und Jugendlichen Schulpsychologin Karin
feigler merkt das jeden Tag
Stelle schon viele Belastungsreaktionen
fest die Fallzahlen bei Depressionen bei
Symptomen wie Ängsten sind deutlich
gestiegen es gibt mehr sozialen Rückzug
sozialer Ängste von denen Kinder und
Jugendliche betroffen sind selbst
verletztes Verhalten ist gestiegen zu
ihr kommen Kinder die gemobbt werden
Essstörungen oder Lernschwierigkeiten
haben solche die sich ein Leben ohne
Social Media kaum vorstellen können das
ist dann eine Tür gibt an der man
klopfen kann schätzen die Schülerinnen
und Schüler so der Schulsprecher
in der Schule dass man ja eigentlich
jeden Tag und wenn man ja da Hilfe
braucht dass man die auch sofort
bekommen kann doch eine Haus eigene
Psychologin wie feigle haben die
wenigsten Schulen in der Regel betreut
eine Fachkraft durchschnittlich
5.400 Kinder und Jugendliche sie wird
nur bei Bedarf gerufen so die Corinna
Ehlert
wir hätten schon Ideen was wir alles
noch machen könnten an Schulen mit
Schülergruppen mit lehrergruppen mit
mehr in die Prävention zu gehen ja das
ist gar nicht so weit kommt das können
wir aber mit der Ausstattung die wir im
Moment haben nicht
Ehlert bildet deshalb auch Lehrkräfte
fort sie dürfen sich dann
Beratungslehrer nennen kein Ersatz für
die fehlenden Schulpsychologen aber eine
Ergänzung
nach China da findet am Sonntag der
Parteitag der Kommunisten in Peking
statt der ohnehin mächtige Staats- und
Parteichef shising Ping wird seine
Herrschaft dort wohl noch weiter
ausbauen er setzt auf eine rigorose 0
kovet-politik Protest kaum möglich
Kritik wird im Keim erstickt wie unsere
Korrespondentin Miriam Steimer berichtet
wir wollen Nahrung keine coffe-tests wir
wollen Freiheit keine lockdowns dieser
seltene Protest gestern zeigt die
angespannte Stimmung in Peking denn
während die Partei Tags Delegierten hier
ankommen sitzen wohl 200 Millionen
Menschen im Land im Lockdown auch die
Menschenrechtsanwältin Wangen ü sie
dreht Runden im Innenhof ihres
Wohnkomplexes will lieber nicht stehen
bleiben zwei Männer folgen ihr auf
Schritt und Tritt sie ist eine der ganz
wenigen die offen Kritik äußern
die Null corvette-politik ist ein
Training für die Chinesen um endgültig
zu Sklaven zu werden Menschen die freies
Internet nutzen wissen dass das das Ziel
ist und es nicht um die Pandemie geht
für viele bedeutet Lockdown auch kein
Job kein Einkommen
Arbeitslosigkeit ist im Anstieg hier und
das ist natürlich etwas was aufs Gemüter
Leute drückte der Konsum liegt am Boden
und deswegen braucht China um die
Wirtschaft weiterhin aufrecht zu halten
den europäischen Konsumenten
für Restaurants ist das schwer
Fiebermessen aktueller corona-test sonst
kommt keiner rein wenn doch müsste das
Restaurant wochenlang schließen das
können sie sich nicht leisten
es kommen nur noch sehr wenige Touristen
im Vergleich zu früher sind nur noch 5%
übrig
der Mann mit dem Protestbanner wurde
verhaftet Bilder davon zensiert an jeder
Brücke gibt es heute Sicherheitsleute
vor dem Parteitag gilt in China nicht
nur 0 kovid sondern auch null Prozent
jetzt zum Sport zur Europa League
Norbert da sind Union und Freiburg ja
weiter auf Erfolgskurs wir sind nicht
nur in der Bundesliga-Spitze die
Breisgauer gestern Abend nach dem 4:0 in
Norden schon sicher in der Ko-Runde ja
und auch die Berliner können nach dem
Sieg gegen Malmö weiterkommen
in Köpenick hält sich Union auch
international in ungewohnten Regionen
das später elfmeter-tour gegen Malmö
durch Robin Knoche sichert den
bundesligatabellenführer Europa weiter
Auftritte mindestens in der Conference
League kommen sie in der Europa League
weiter könnten die Berliner zum Beispiel
auf den FC Barcelona treffen ja toll ein
Teilziel mal erreicht es war eines der
Ziele europäisch zu überwintern Freiburg
übersteht beim FC Nord zum ersten Mal
eine internationale Gruppenphase der
Koreaner who Yong Jong trifft zum 40
Endstand für das Team von Christian
Streich nach corona-infektion wieder an
der Seitenlinie folgt nun eine
bundesliga-reise nach München
die werden natürlich auf uns losgehen am
Sonntag aber wir haben keine Angst
uns geht's gut es wird ein Spitzenspiel
mit den Freiburgern als Tabellenzweiten
einen Platz vor den Bayern
ja für Köln dagegen in der Conference
League wird es mit dem Weiterkommen
schwierig nach der 0:2-niederlage
gestern Abend den Belgrad zum Handball
im Januar beginnt die WM die deutsche
Mannschaft hat mit den Vorbereitungen
begonnen ja und gleich im ersten
Testspiel eine Niederlage einstecken
müssen 33:37 gegen Schweden
Enttäuschung und Ernüchterung bei der
DHB-Auswahl das Team von Alfred
gießlerson musste gegen den
Europameister Lehrgeld bezahlen das ist
ganz klar
nicht du schon spielt und oder vor allem
waren die Schweden ja mindestens besser
einzig Kapitän Johannes Golla überzeugte
mit 12 Treffern bei der Kreisläufer
bester deutscher Werfer aus der Hand
gegeben wurde das Spiel zu Beginn der
zweiten Halbzeit die Offensive
unflexibel die Abwehr überfordert
Schweden konnte einen neuen Toreführung
erspielen immerhin die DHB-Auswahl
kämpfte 33 zu 37 der Endstand schon
morgen gibt es die Chance besser zu
machen im letzten Länderspiel des Jahres
in Spanien
das war es am Sport Dankeschön Norbert
nach kräftigem Regen heute Nacht im
Südwesten wird es morgen wechselhaft und
danach ungewöhnlich warm mehr dazu
gleich von Katja horneffer das heute
journal können Sie um 22 Uhr sehen mit
Christian Sievers auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute zogen erstmal nur
kleine Regenschauer über unseren Weg
aber dann kam dicker Regen von
Frankreich heran und der wird sich auch
in der Nacht weiter ostwärts ausbreiten
innerhalb von 24 Stunden können im
Schwarzwald 30 bis 50 örtlich sogar an
die 70 Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter
fallen Bäche werden da über die Ufer
treten das wird eine sehr milde Nacht
mit 15 bis 10 Grad und auch morgen über
Tag ist es mild 15 Grad erwarten uns in
den östlichen Mittelgebirgen bis zu 20
Grad zum Beispiel rund um Erfurt der
Regen der Nacht sieht auswärts ab aber
schon bald wird er abgelöst von neuem
Regen hier im Westen und Richtung
Belgien und Niederlande kann es am
Nachmittag auch für Gewitter reichen am
freundlichsten ist es morgen am
Alpenrand und zwischen der Lausitz und
Schleswig-Holstein dazu weht der Wind
stark bis stürmisch aus südwestlichen
Richtungen und der Sonntag bringt dann
hier im Südwesten schon Temperaturen bis
25 Grad am Alpenrand strahlt dazu die
Sonne viel Sonnenschein gibt es auch in
Schleswig-Holstein allerdings nur bei 16
in der Mitte Deutschlands allerdings ist
es stark bewölkt bis bedeckt da kann es
auch etwas regnen guten Abend